is Ruby Rose throwing shade at Katy  Perry's new music gonna keep people  guessing all of my songs have had  meanings they've never been  one-dimensional and I think that this  song just poses a question in your mind  Ruby seems to be coming to her powell  taylor swift's defense after perry  released her latest single swish swish  what some are calling a dish track to  t-swift former shellfish she don't you  come to me you calculated that you know  cuz you're a joker and now my good side  give it queen the 31 year old actress  slammed Perry's new song Thursday  tweeting purposeful poop to BOM apetite  to a sloppy mess of writing over the top  of funk agenda stop trying to make wit I  mean fetch happen funny 9 name keeps  coming at you  ah  swish swish fish  Ruby criticized her even further writing  in part to go from rebranding as  political activists only to ditch it and  go low is a bummer